[Musique]
bienvenue sur le plateau d'un tas didata
dire je reçois aujourd'hui guillaume
blanc qui publie l'invention du
colonialisme versé sous titrée pour en
finir avec le mythe de l'éden africain
yaron herman qui sort le déclic créatif
un livre particulièrement utile pendant
le confinement puisqu'il nous explique
comment on développe mais notre
créativité au quotidien la peintre
aurélie gallois dont les peintures
érotiques sont réunies dans un livre
bijoux indiscrets associait des textes
écrits pour l'occasion par des écrivains
comme lydie salvayre catherine robbe
grillet ou peggy sastre et le pianiste
silas bassa pour son nouvel album le
troisième
seul brement intitulé silas mais
commençons tout de suite par notre
époque qu'est ce qui caractérise ce
début de xxième siècle nos invités
réponse en images voici celle de
guillaume blanc c'est ans et en ethiopie
c'est un peu la bande annonce de ce que
vous allez nous de ce que vous racontez
dans votre livre
oui exactement comprendre pourquoi
est-ce que des institutions
internationales comme l'unesco le wwf
lui cn recommande l'expulsion de
villages et de villageois comme ceux de
gi joe en ethiopie donc l'avant là prêt
pour soi disant lutter contre la
dégradation écologique en s'en prenant
des paysans qui malheureusement ne
participe pas alors on le voit c'était
du temps où il y avait encore des
habitants dans ce parc national en
dessous c'est quand il n'y en a plus et
puis il ya une troisième photo vous
vouliez con qu'on regarde la voici
alors ça c'est une fois que le parc
national est devenu un parc national et
qui a des touristes oui voilà et c'est
pour souligner le paradoxe quand
beaucoup dix ans de gens qui sont sur
prier en se disant bon certes il ya des
expulsions des déplacements mais en même
temps la nature est protégé sauf que si
on fait le calcul du coût écologique de
la visite d'un parc en afrique
donc ce qui hélas cette photographie
bien les bâtons d'aluminium pour ses
tantes ses de l'extraction de bauxite
les randonneurs qui ont une veste en
gore-tex du téflon la veste la petite
polaires des résidus de pétrole
le billet en avion 0,5 tonne de co2
généralement un smartphone donc d'encore
de l'extraction de matières premières et
bien finalement venir visiter un parc
naturel en afrique c'est l'équivalent de
détruire dans le monde
les ressources qui sont protégés dans ce
parc d'où l'absurdité sociale mais aussi
finalement écologique et peut-être les
parcs serait davantage des trompe l'oeil
qui masque le vrai problème la
dégradation massive de l'environnement
sur toute la planète
on en parle dans quelques instants quand
on parle de votre livre on va voir tout
à coup les parcs nationaux en afrique
sous un autre angle
votre photo avoué yaron herman c'est un
dessin idée très drôle faut près les
avez vous choisi enfin c'est que ça
résume justement la situation actuelle
cette histoire des libraires et de cette
idée des produits essentiellement sa
forme il m'intrigue beaucoup
j'aimerais bien la règle de base ce qui
est essentiel à l'homme de manière
générale qui peut le déterminer
est ce que on doit mettre l'accent sur
ce qui nous fait survivre et peut-être
pas sur ce qui nous fait vraiment où
vivre mieux
il faudrait boire d'ailleurs je crois
que c'était secondes de produits
essentiels c'est peut-être typiquement
français d'ailleurs il faudra il faudra
faire une enquête
votre image à vous aurélie gallois c'est
celle ci plus mystérieuse de quoi
s'agit-il au côté de qui alors je ne
fais pas je ne sais pas de qui il s'agit
sur cette photo mais
ne pouvant pas choisir parmi tous les
désastres dont bono autres invités pour
nous parler
je suis retombé sur cette photo que
j'avais acheté dans une brocante aux
quêtes code donc là en pleine élection
américaine je trouvais que c'était un
bon clin d'oeil et en même temps cette
photo résume assez bien notre époque
pour moi elle est pleine d'absurdité
agde assez agressive aussi de
narcissisme d'une forme de solitude
aussi un un peu pathétique
d'obscénité le fusil à la main n'est pas
la fleur au fusil non la cigarette au
chili et je trouvais que c'était pour
pour mon sujet s'était pas mal lui il
est lé sexe au repos verra que dans
votre peinture les sexes sont sont plus
plus dressé n'est ce pas parfait et
enfin l'image de 2,6 nasba ça c'est une
photo que vous at-elle vais peut-être
prise vous même nom si l'aspect ça oui
bon il faut que je me remette de cette
photo dernière parce qu'elle était
vraiment superbe
écoutez oui c'est une photo que j'ai
prise moi-même en l'an 2000 comme on
peut voir à paris et en fait je pareil
comme aurélie je me dis je vais aller
vers quelque chose de catastrophique de
2 comment vit un moment difficile donc
je préférais ramener ça à quelque chose
de personnel
et quand je pensais à ces dernières
vingt ans je me suis rendu compte grâce
à vous et donc finalement j'ai réalisé
que ce 20ème siècle je l' ai vécu
surtout en france et c'est en l'an 2000
que j'ai visité pour la première fois à
paris donc j'étais là avec bruno gilbert
un grand pianiste argentin c'est un king
bourse j'ai travaillé avec lui à monaco
par contre mais
à la fin de ce jour j'ai demandé que je
voulais passer par paris et connaître
paris et donc j'ai passé une petite
semaine à paris et j'ai eu un coup de
coeur et donc j'ai fait cette photo
avec ce pigeon qui vont qui peut être
sans mode et beaucoup de choses et aussi
dire que halo finalement donc je suis
resté donc ses 20 ans ici et dire que
c'est une façon aussi une opportunité
pour moi de remercier et de de soutenir
la france parce que c'est un pays qui
m'a ouvert accueilli les complètement
ouvert les portes et j'ai appris
beaucoup de choses et bien commençons et
c'est avec vous guillaume blanc qu'on
commence cette émission vous êtes
historien de l'environnement spécialisée
dans l'afrique contemporaine vous
enseigner à l'université rennes 2 et
vous publiez donc l'invention du
colonialisme vert pour en finir avec le
mythe de l'éden africain c'est quoi le
mythe de l'éden africain faut que vous
nous le décrit vielles d'abord le mythe
de l'éden africain penser au roi lion
c'est à dire une afrique vierge sauvage
naturel en fait l'histoire nous permet
de voir que ce mythe remonte à la fin du
19e siècle
en fait quand les colons qui partent
tenter leur chance en afrique mais ils
laissent derrière eux une europe qui se
transforme radicalement sous les coups
de l'urbanisation l'industrialisation et
ils sont persuadés de retrouver en
afrique
cette nature qui a disparu chez eux et
en fait le mythe va être perpétuée
alors que ce soit stanley livingstone
puis hemingway et les neiges du
kilimandjaro puis karen blixen et out of
africa retard la ferme africaine
et puis après l'époque coloniale les
racines du ciel de gary le national
geographic lonely planet tous ces
produits culturels qui nous décrivent
une afrique édénique une afrique de
faune de flore de panoramas le problème
c'est que cette afrique n'existe pas
elle n'a jamais existé et nous sommes
persuadés du contraire
alors je vous corrige un tout petit peu
si vous permettez à guillaume blanc est
la foule elle existe cette afrique j'ai
derrière moi ont joué devant des fidèles
de photos que j'ai prises moi même je
suis allé la voir cette afrique elle
existe bien ce que l'on découvre
en lisant votre livre c'est le prix qui
est payé pour que cette afrique là celle
qu'on va voir défiler derrière moi
existe et notamment le fait que vous
dites que plus la nature est détruite
chez nous plus on veut la sauver là bas
et c'est ce que l'on fait avec des parcs
nationaux comme comme ce que qui abrite
ces animaux sauvages
aujourd'hui mais ça a un prix voilà
alors ça a un prix et je me permets de
vous corriger à mon tour c'est que cette
afrique sang africain existe mais pour
une simple raison les parcs nationaux
que vous avez dû visiter
ils ne sont pas vides ils ont été vidés
de leurs habitants et le prix à payer en
effet bien sûr le long 25 siècles c'est
de 1 à 14 millions de cultivateurs et
bergers qui ont été expulsés des parcs
africain est aujourd'hui sont encore des
millions de cultivateurs et de bergers
qui sont sanctionnés d'amendés voire de
peines de prison pour cultiver la terre
faire pâturer leurs troupeaux pour
habiter leur maison et c'est cette
criminelle et de criminalisation au
quotidien
qui en effet est le prix à payer pour
que cette afrique continue d'exister
alors criminalisation ou comme la photo
le montre ici folklorisation à souhait
également des populations qui sont
intégrés qui doivent être intégrées à ce
paysage local
oui elle en la photo qu'on voyait là ce
sont des sondés masai qui sont des agro
pasteurs c'est comme ça qu'on dit oh
voilà ils sont chez eux
je suis allé les voir dans leur village
où effectivement ils sont à l'extérieur
du parc national et je me suis rendu et
ils vivent une vie quand même très
dépendante du parc national puisque ils
ne peuvent plus se livrer comme ils se
livraient l agro un gros élevages qui
est dans leur tradition depuis toujours
et en effet alors là c'est vraiment les
deux problèmes
on va avoir dans des cas extrêmes des
quatre folklorisation voit par exemple
dans le sud de l'ethiopie dans le pré du
parc national de l'omo on a des
populations mort six mois j'ai pu voir
on y reste en plus d'une journée en fait
des populations en jean tee shirt avec
les mêmes paysages derrière dira
il est 9 heures le bus arrive on enlève
le jean le tee shirt on met le pagne bon
les touristes un dollar la photo 14
heures les touristes repartent vers
d'autres aventures
on remet le jean et le t-shirt bon ça ce
pourrait être une des conséquences mais
la deuxième comme vous dites c'est que
c'est la dépendance de ces populations
aux parcs nationaux et au tourisme
quid d'une période de pandémie donc
quand il n'ya plus de tourisme qu'elle
est en fait le mode de vie sur lequel
peu ces populations peuvent se reposer
pour continuer à vivre si leur mode de
vie est entièrement tourné vers la
consommation de la nature c'est un
problème qui est en train de d'avoir une
phase encore plus réelle aujourd'hui
elles refont ce que vous expliquez dans
votre livre c'est que de grandes
institutions occidentales comme l'unesco
le double d'abord lieu de beaulieu f
au fond organise la la déshumanisation
d'une partie du continent à vouloir
vouloir naturalisés des régions entières
au fond on dézingue déshumanise ces
régions entières
on chasse les habitants on leur met des
amendes et c'est une star critères pour
pouvoir être reconnu et protégé par
l'unesco
il faut qu'on ait expulsé les gens mais
est ce qu'on n'a pas fait la même chose
dans nos parcs nationaux à nous parle
des états unis par exemple du canada
on parle beaucoup de donald trump par
exemple le fait qu'ils veuillent de
nouveau elle est explorée s'il n'ya pas
du gaz au fond du grand canyon ça fait
un scandale parce que on a chassé la
plupart du temps les gens du parc de
départ de nuit wyoming
c'est quelque chose pour fait pas
seulement en afrique
alors vous avez tout à fait raison le
premier parc national qui a été créée
dans le monde sert yellowstone en 1872
et puis d'autre part qu'un au canada aux
états unis où là encore les parcs
n'était pas évident
ils ont été vidés qu'est-ce que c'était
un moyen pour les colons aussi de
planter le drapeau dans des territoires
qu'ils avaient du mal à contrôler la
bleue la nature le permettait en europe
il ya eu moins d'expulsion mais
attention ce n'était pas pour pour
autant pas violent le premier parc
national qui a été créé en france dans
la vanoise en 63 quand le ministre de
l'agriculture est arrivé pour
l'inaugurer des villageois sont sortis
avec leurs fusils en disant vous posez
un coup de peinture sur le rocher
on vous sort un coup de fusil en fait la
seule différence c'est qu'en afrique ça
ne s'est jamais arrêté voilà la seule
différence alors qu'en europe aux états
unis au contraire et en afrique il y a
de plus en plus une réappropriation par
les populations
mais dans des logiques qui sont tels que
la conservation communautaire n'atteint
jamais les objectifs sociaux qu'elle
s'est fixée c'est là en fait le
changement c'est que le traitement de la
nature africaine par le monde reste une
exception
aujourd'hui encore et vous dit que non
seulement on a expulsé entre 1 et 14
millions de gens c'est pas tant que ça à
l'échelle de l'afrique 1 c'est entre 0,2
et et 1,5 pour cent de la population
enfin c'est beaucoup parce que ce sont
eux qui en sont victimes et puis surtout
vous dites que c'est mauvais pour les
pour la diversité
alors là c'est plus étonnant parce que
quand on voit les parcs nationaux aussi
bien aux états unis qu'en afrique mais
restons sur ceux de l'afrique parce que
c'est ça qui nous préoccupe
on se dit bah la biodiversité elle est
formidable et est en effet elle est
préservé ne nous le cachons pas elle est
préservée mais l'exemple que je vous ai
donné c'est pour ça que je voulais vous
donner la photo sur les touristes ont
saisi le coût écologique est dramatique
c'est justement révélateur c'est ça la
matrice du colonialisme vers tel qu'il a
été inventé et souvent les formes
actuelles de cette dissociation entre la
nature d'un côté la culture de l'autre
c'est à dire que croire que la nature
est préservée uniquement là où il n'y a
pas d'homme c'est en fait s'exonérer de
tout les dégâts qu'ont cause partout
ailleurs je peux mener cette vie là
puisque ici c'est préserver et si
malheureusement comme vous dites on s'en
prend à ses agriculteurs et ses bergers
et c'est vrai qu'on peut avoir une
vision disant bon après tout c'est pas
un nombre si colossal mais le problème
c'est que c'est trop peu l'oeil que sans
les parcs nationaux où les politiques
internationales global croire que la
nature est préservée et qu'on fait
quelque chose pour la lutte écologique
et en fait ça masquer l'évidence c'est à
dire la destruction de la planète
entière et la planète ne survivra pas en
s'en prenant à des agriculteurs et des
bergers puisqu'au contraire il faudrait
essayer de suivre la sobriété écologique
qui est la leur voyez le le grand
paradoxe en fait nature ici destruction
ailleurs ça ne marche pas vous dit
guillaume blanche la question écologique
en afrique est influencé par le
colonialisme d'où le titre de votre
livre le colonialisme vert depuis le
début au fond depuis le début de la
colonisation
on veut sauver l'afrique des africains
et on le voit bien quand on regarde les
films qui ont été tournés en afrique du
temps de la colonisation ou ceux qui
racontent l afrique du temps de la
colonisation
les seuls africains qu'on voyait dans
ces films là c'était les animaux
sauvages et depuis que l'afrique a été
décolonisée à chaque fois qu'on voit des
africa dans les films au fond on voit
bien que ce sont eux qui sont
responsables
c'est toujours comme ça qu'on nous les
montre de la catastrophe de que connaît
l'afrique depuis qu'on l'aide des cullen
et réaliser des les colonisés c'est
toujours la même morale laufon
ce sont les africains qui font du mal à
l'afrique exactement et c et c'est là où
l'histoire permet en fait dix ans de
regarder un peu plus sereinement le
présent le mot
adorer la photo de votre invité sur ce
chasseur effectivement à l'époque
coloniale fin 19ème siècle quand la
colonisation conduit à une dégradation
sans précédent de la faune animale 65000
éléphants parents qui sont tués ou à la
fin du 19e siècle 95 millions d'hectares
de forêts qui sont déboisés en afrique
et en asie entre 1850 et 1920 et bien
les colons ne sont pas capables de voir
que la dégradation à laquelle il assiste
et bien et de leur fait et il invente à
ce moment là le mythe du bon chasseur et
du mauvais chasseur le bon chasseur
l'homme blanc qui chasse le trophée avec
bravoure au fusil et le mauvais chasseur
le braconnier noir qui chasse la
nourriture avec cruauté et bien ce mythe
sous des formes différentes et encore
perpétuer aujourd'hui et l'idée selon
laquelle les africains bien sûr que dans
toutes sociétés africaines les hommes et
les femmes exploite la terre en bien
comme en mal
sont des êtres humains comme nous comme
vous et moi comme tout le monde mais
l'idée selon laquelle en afrique
les paysans africains dégraderait ça
c'est une idée héritées de la
colonisation et qui explique
qu'aujourd'hui encore moi ma famille
vient des cévennes un parc national
l'unesco et l'état français valorise
dans les cévennes l'agriculture et le
pastoralisme en disant que c'est un
exemple d'adaptation mais en afrique on
a uniquement des histoires de
dégradation et là c'est le poids du
passé colonial qui continue d'orienter
le présent et peu importe que ce mythe
soit coloniale le problème c'est qu'ils
continuent aujourd'hui à faire des
ravages
au fond vous dites qu'il ya aucune étude
globale n'a jamais réellement analyser
l'état écologique de l'afrique et on vit
sur 20 un autre mythe depuis toujours
c'est que l'afrique était de été
couverte d'une immense forêt vierge et
que ce sont les africains qu'ils ont
dégradé et que donc il faudrait et que
tout ce qu'ils ont pu faire que ce soit
les sentiers les ce que vous soit que
vous faites allusion les pâturages les
cultures au fret une dégradation de la
forêt vierge qui devrait
qui devait être à leur place voilà
exactement est là encore faut remonter
quand même un peu à l'histoire mais
quand les botanistes fin 19ème siècle
découvre bien les paysages des villages
en afrique de l'ouest avec des ceintures
forestière ils sont influencés par la
théorie du climax comme quoi il y aurait
eu une forêt primaire
attention au vocabulaire les forêts
primaires c'est comme les ethnies c'est
un mot qui a été inventé par les
européens et ça n'existerait que dans
les anciennes colonies
nous on a des peuples certains ont des
ethnies et bien la forêt primaire dans
les écologies semi arides d'afrique
subsaharienne
ça n'existe quasiment nulle part comme
en europe
les africains ont créé la condition des
pousses de pouce des arbres avec de la
savane puis de l'agriculture et du
brûlis qui a donné des arbustes puis des
arbres ils sont dotés d'une couverture
forestière jamais abondant que jamais
épuisé mais les botanistes ont fait la
lecture selon laquelle on aurait eu une
forêt vierge morcelé par cette explosion
démographique africaine et aujourd'hui
encore al gore par exemple qui est un
militant écologiste convaincu et qui
décrit mais avec une précis une rare
précision les dégâts du changement
climatique mais même al gore s'appuie
sur des chiffres de la déforestation par
exemple en ethiopie qui sont des
chiffres fantaisistes qui ne repose sur
aucune étude écologique
et pourtant ces chiffres sont encore
aujourd'hui d'actualité alors qu'on a
besoin de réelle étude
mais nous ne sommes pas capables de dire
en europe combien il y avait de forêt il
ya un siècle au pourcentage près nom
serait capable en afrique ou en ethiopie
de lire 40% 3%
non ces chiffres circulent au point
qu'on heureux les remet plus en cause
mais il faut les remettre en cause
et alors c'est il ya quand même des
animaux sauvages en afrique comment il
n'y en a plus quasiment ailleurs comment
les protéger parce qu'aujourd'hui il ya
des gouvernements souverains en afrique
il n'ya pas que des institutions
internationales
comment faire pour que ces gorilles qui
sont dernières mois continuent d'être
protégés dans la forêt impénétrable en
ouganda où les lions et les les
hippopotames que l'on voyait juste avant
soit en tanzanie soit au kenya où les
rhinocéros en afrique du sud pour ça il
faut bien des parcs
alors il faut des parcs où il faut aussi
se demander
ça fait deux siècles à peu près où un
siècle et demi on va dire que les parcs
existe parce que les africains sont en
train de détruire la faune sauvage ça
fait quand même un siècle et demi que
cette afrique est censé être détruite
un moment il faut quand même se demander
quand est-ce qu'elle serait pas censée
avoir été détruite puisque ça fait cent
cinquante ans qu'on dit les africains
sont en train de la détruire
et puis on peut se demander à qui
faut-il s'en prendre au grand réseau de
braconniers qui existe qui détruisent la
grande faune et c'est à eux qu'il faut
s'attaquer et d'ailleurs on auquel des
institutions internationales s'attaque
bien réellement et des états africains
aussi en revanche il faut se demander
est-ce que des populations qui vivent
d'une agriculture de subsistance
est ce que ces populations sont
réellement des braconniers - dans le
parc national que j'ai commencé à
étudier à l'origine de ce livre en
ethiopie il ya un bouquetin qui
s'appelle le wali à l'ibex et bien cela
fait 60 ans qu'il est en train de
disparaître
selon les archives de l'unesco du wwf de
lui ce n est bien ils étaient 150
bouquetins en 1960 puis 300 puis 6 ans
puis 900 puis 1200 e mille pardons
aujourd'hui mais l'expulsion des
populations est justifié pour la survie
du bouquetin populations qui sont passés
de 3000 habitants à 12000 donc ils n'ont
pas fait disparaître ce fameux
bouquetins on peut aussi se dire que la
co évolution entre humains non humain
est possible avec des agriculteurs qui
vivent d'une agriculture de subsistance
avec des grands braconniers et des
braconniers réel non pas du tout et là
il faut lutter mais on s'en prend aux
mauvaises personnes généralement
l'invention du colonialisme vert c'est
le titre du livre de guillaume blanc qui
vient de paraître chez flammarion
[Musique]
yaron herman vous êtes un célèbre
pianiste de jazz mais c'est pour un
livre que je vous invitais aujourd'hui
le déclic créatif qui paraît chez fayard
un livre tout à fait approprié à notre
situation actuelle puisque nous sommes
confinés pour un mois au moins et que
vous nous expliquer en détail comment en
profiter pour déployer notre créativité
au quotidien il faut savoir qu'avant
d'être de devenir pianiste de jazz vous
consacriez au basket
espériez faire une grande carrière de
basketteur et puis à 16 ans
accident obligé de vous reconvertir et
vous décidez de vous mettre au piano à
16 ans a priori c'est trop tard il y
arrivera jamais etc etc
et puis vous allez y arriver quand même
et aujourd'hui vous êtes réputé pour
votre style et pour vos albums alors ce
livre là n'est pas destiné à nous
transformer tous deux tendus confinement
en virtuose du jardinage du piano du
dessin ou je ne sais quoi mais
simplement de chercher la créativité qui
est en nous comme vous le savez chercher
la vôtre au fond à ce moment-là rhin
absolument et moi j'ai découvert aussi
par une contrainte extérieure c'est à
dire que nous on rêve initial de devenir
un espèce michael jordan juifs à
lunettes n'a pas vraiment fonctionné
je me suis blessé et du coup j'ai
découvert la musique comme ça et c'est
le voyage est partie de la façon la plus
la plus surprenante et j'ai découvert au
fur et à mesure grâce à cette
méthodologie que j'essaye aussi de
expliqué dans le livre que c'est
possible que la créativité est à la
portée de nos tous et que nous avons
tous quelque chose à exprimer qui est
unique à différents niveaux céderont à
ce qu'on souhaite accomplir mais que
c'est possible
vous parlez de contraintes il ya une
vous donner beaucoup d'exemples dans ce
livre et c'est ce qui rend savoureux
vous parlez d'un voyage que vous avez dû
effectuer au japon elle très long voyage
12 heures de temps vous essayez de
dormir et vous êtes importunés par le
bruit de la climatisation qui est juste
au dessus de vous et ce billet est
infernal et voilà une contrainte dont
vous allez faire quelque chose raconte
nous aurons besoin d'avions pour tokyo
avec une clean qui
qui a été cassé tout simplement donc il
faisait un bruit historiques ou pas
trois temps qui faisait évidemment comme
j'ai l'habitude maintenant de
reconnaître des rythmes je travaille sur
ça et c'est pour moi aussi une qualité
la créativité ça ça va reconnaître des
patères en temps réel on est l'heure de
naissance
donc du coup ses rythmes qui était très
énervant pendant très longtemps et des
nuits musicales au fur et à mesure et
mon imaginaire a commencé à superposer
mélodies par dessus et ensuite rentrer
en france
évidemment j'ai noté cette idée là pour
ne pas lever le pied et entre en france
je commence à jouer avec ce motif là il
se trouve qu'à ce moment là j'ai
travaillé une oeuvre de bach
donc tu avais le motif de la clim et il
ya un sebastian bach et étrangement en
regardant les deux partitions je me suis
dit oh la la qu'est-ce qui se passerait
si je fais un mélange entre ces deux
zones les moins totalement improbable et
finalement ça a donné quelque chose de
nouveau tout filmé ses fast life un
morceau d'un de vos albums on écoute
fastlife donc le résultat de la
climatisation de bach et puis diaro
neerman quand même sa créativité à lui
[Musique]
non
on l'entend bien la clim un montant bien
la clé m'ont fait une pause
yaron on se retrouve juste après
[Musique]
toujours avec yaron herman qui publie le
déclic créatif chez fayard
alors évidemment il faut s'imaginer
confiné en train de se dire me tiens si
je développe la créativité est une
phrase un peu tarte comme ça mais elle
dit bien ce qu'elle veut dire au fond la
plupart du temps le problème c'est qu'on
renonce vite on se dit bon ben je vais
j'ai pas le temps j'ai pas le j'ai pas
le moral vous dites que c'est là dessus
qu'il faut là aussi vous donner je
trouve un très bel exemple vous dis il
faut s'inspirer des bébés qui apprennent
à marcher mais qu'apprend on m'a passé
il se pose pas trop de questions il
commence à marcher il tombe se relève
lire aux marges
il retourne et y rester jusqu'au moment
où ils arrivent à traverser la pièce et
cette attitude et wind quelque part qui
n'est pas un train de se comparer
forcément aux adultes on se dit dans
cette vidéo où la glace est 10 fois que
je suis tombé peut-être marcher c'est
pas tout à fait pour moi te dire vous
savez quoi avant de m'élancer je vais
quand même faire des études de marché
d'avoir un diplôme je vais pouvoir enfin
donc j'ai des fastes on est éduqué dans
la ferme
non c'est cette capacité là le garder
une espèce de d'attitude joyeuse et sans
complexe comme cela ça fait quelque
chose évidemment c'est désagréable de se
sentir lille mais quand on comprend que
c'est une phase un peu il inévitable de
l'apprentissage on indique par et 1
poursuit mais aussi de tous ces exemples
que vous le donnez vous les avez piocher
à l'époque où vous appreniez le plein
le piano vous l'avez enrichi par votre
expérience depuis
parce qu'effectivement on imagine bien
yaron herman ou qui que ce soit d'autre
se lançant dans une nouvelle activité
dans un domaine qu'il ne connaît pas
effectivement la tendance et de se
comparer aux autres et de se dire oh là
là c'est trop tard j'y arriverai pas je
suis trop mauvais ils ont tellement
d'avancé sur moi effectivement comme le
bébé doit se dire en voyant les adultes
marcher beaucoup mieux que lui il
devrait rapidement en tirer la
conclusion qu'il n'est pas fait pour
marcher oui mais ça aussi il ya
plusieurs éléments de réponse c'est que
la première c'est que la comparaison est
inévitable pour ce combat
sauf si elle nous coupent tout notre
plaisir de pratiquer cette activité et
donc l'idée de tout traité créatif au
delà de devenir un performeur d'élite ou
quoi que ce soit c'est de se faire
plaisir c'est faire du bien c'est à dire
que c'est un espace sacré à l'intérieur
duquel on peut accéder à quelque chose
qui nous est propre
donc d'abord ont créé pour soi à partir
de ce moment là on peut se comparer par
exemple pour apprendre des autres où ils
ont fait c'est incroyable on analyse on
essaie de d'apprendre mais c'est vrai
qu'il faut préserver cette idée qu on
crée d'abord pour soi vous dites aussi
et ça aussi ça s'adapte particulièrement
à cette période dans laquelle nous nous
trouvons aujourd'hui celle du
confinement
vous dites que c'est pas mauvais de
s'entourer d'un petit rituel au fond on
rentre un moment dans un dans quelque
chose d'indéfini qui va être le moment
où on veut devenir créatif et que le
rituel peut nous y aider
c'est pas une vue de l'esprit ça existe
vraiment et pas seulement pour les
grands artistes qui aiment s'entourer de
l'or de l'or gris gris avant de monter
sur scène
non c'est normal tout à fait normal je
construis à tous des éléments dans notre
vie quotidienne qui nous aide un peu à
être plus à même que concentré un plus
présent à plus jouer eux et je pense
qu'il faut qu'on vous mette les éléments
de l'autre côté pour faciliter justement
l'accès à cet espace est de manière
générale quand on joue de qu'il ya un
jeu ça veut dire qu'il ya des règles
s'il ya des règles ça veut dire qu'il ya
quelque chose à établir donc pour moi la
partie la plus agréable dont les jeux et
la création c'est l'invention des règles
et les règles c'est un peu comme des
rituels on s'est dit ok on va créer une
contrainte choisi qui va être un espèce
de catalyseur de possibilité par exemple
on peut penser à période bleue des
picasso et ses systèmes des douze dont
de schoenberg aux quatre saisons de
vivaldi les grands artistes savez que
c'est pas forcément en élargissant leurs
champs du possible qu'ils allaient être
créatif mais plutôt on établit sont soit
des rituels au quotidien soit en
établissant des règles qui vont ouvrir
leur créativité justement alors la
créativité dont vous parlez dans ce
livre yaron herman
évidemment ça consistant dans toutes les
activités artistiques et dieu sait si le
confinement c'est propice à apprendre un
nouvel instrument à se mettre à dessiner
à faire de la poterie de la broderie
mais aussi pourquoi pas inventé une
appli ou à créer une entreprise au fond
ça aussi c'est de la créativité
bien sûr on a trop souvent cantonné la
créativité on l'a réservée à une élite
sur des artistes des entrepreneurs
généraux etc
et moi je lutte pour que justement on
intégrer tous cette attitude de
créativité dans nos vies ça peut être me
dit et ça peut être amendée une
association que vous avez dit et d'une
multiplicité d'activités à tout à fait
infini et voilà c'est une attitude à
adopter plus qu'une activité proprement
dit et alors vous faites quelque chose
d'assez amusant dans ce livre vous dites
que plutôt que de se faire une liste
pour réussir ce que tous les adolescents
font un jour ou l'autre
voilà ce qu'il faut pour que je
réussisse vous vous dites faut se faire
une liste pour échouer
oui je pense que c'est bien aussi de
faire une expo réussir ça peut être très
utile c'est-à-dire d'avoir un programme
optimale pour réussir bien organiser son
temps c'était quelles sont mes buts à
court moyen et long terme c'est très
utile je ne crache pas dessus mais en
même temps il est beaucoup plus facile
d'éviter l'échec quand on sait où il se
trouve donc en établissant une liste
pourrait jouer on repère un peu les
pièges en un mot c'est à dire par
exemple actuellement pour bien profiter
de ce temps du confinement
je sais que année danger imminent pour
nous tous c'est peut-être un peu déplacé
de le dire ici à la télé hier en tout
cas mais de regarder trop
les deux-tiers trop les réseaux sociaux
d'être constamment bombardés par le flux
incessant d'informations
c'est à dire voilà je sais que moi si je
tombe des dons voilà ça donne un coup au
moral et je vais pas être très créatif
donc ça va aussi se préserver et
qu'elles sont quelles sont mes habitudes
qui font en sorte qu' on est plus à même
de ne pas se penser d'être minée aux
devoirs ou d'échouer vous dites très
bien dans ce livre yaron herman que la
pire forme d'échec au fond c'est de ne
pas essayer donc vous nous encore et je
tousse à essayer quel que soit le
domaine dans lequel on a envie d'être
créatif essayons et vous dites que là on
dispose de ce qu'il ya de plus précieux
c'est le temps enfin en tout cas pour
ceux qui sont confinés vraiment et qui
ne sont pas censés télétravail et parce
que quand même la plupart des gens ont
directivité mais on a du temps quand
même
oui absolument et c'est temps là est
précieux et sacrée et je pense que c'est
un peu illusion ne se croit que ce qu'on
a du temps globalement tout le temps
sauf quand on le néglige on n'utilise
pas de la façon optimale
là c'est flagrant là on est coupés de
toutes les relations sociales de nos
lieux de travail etc pour les artistes
c'est terrible parce que nous on est
déconnecté du public des salles de
concerts des tournées comme pour
beaucoup d'autres gens et justement on
pourrait croire c'est beaucoup plus
facile maintenant on a le temps mais je
crois que c'est peut-être un peu plus
difficile parce que sinon n'est pas
discipliné si on établit pas justement
ces rituels en disant ok ce matin je
blogue en matinée ou n'importe quel
autre aurait acquis vous plaît ce ton là
il peut vraiment c'est vaporiser a très
vite volatilisé de façon exceptionnelle
donc c'est à nous aussi de savoir 30
voilà le prendre pour aller à la
rencontre de crise qu'on a de plus
précieux filmant ça s'intitule le déclic
créatif et c'est publié chez fayard
[Musique]
aurélie gallois vous êtes peintre et
vous publiez bijoux indiscrets un livre
qui rassemble vos peintures érotiques a
couplé à des textes rédigés pour
l'occasion par des écrivains comme lydie
salvayre catherine robbe grillet peggy
sastre simonetta greggio ou l'architecte
ricardo montoya les bijoux indiscrets
c'est le titre d'un roman libertin de
diderot vous l'avez fait exprès oui oui
c'est un clin d'oeil à un hommage à ceux
à ce roman érotique mais qui a été
publié anonymement sous le manteau par
diderot qui n'assumait pas totalement ce
récit et qui a qui m'a beaucoup inspiré
quand j'ai décidé de mettre ses petites
peintures dans des boîtes à bijoux un
peu par hasard je rejoins ce que disait
yaron sur les petits accidents ou les
restrictions de créativité par quoi et
donc je trouvais que c'était un clin
d'oeil obligé alors on en voit derrière
moi il y en a une ravissante qui est ici
il y a les peintures sont sont
normalement dissimulés dans des écrins
un bijou comme celui ci on va les voir
après en plus grand sortis de leurs de
leur écrin mais ça faisait beaucoup
xviiie siècle justement de cacher des
peintures dans des écrins dans des
petites boîtes
aujourd'hui on n'y est plus obligé
puisque il ya des images pornographiques
photos vidéos très facilement
accessibles sur internet qui ne sont
plus interdite aux moins de 18 ans que
de pure forme
alors pourquoi les avoir de nouveaux
dissimulé qu'est-ce qui vous amuse est
là dedans alors de me de me situer dans
une tradition peut-être parce que je
fais de la peinture à l'huile donc c'est
déjà un peu traditionnelle un peu
classique mais aussi justement parce que
vous venez de dire que on a une une
pléthore de l'image à disposition et ce
dispositif de la boîte qui dissimule
l'image et la petite est ce aussi parce
que là on les voit très grand format
mais il faut savoir qu'elles font 3 cm
de côté pour la plupart sinon on le voit
bien avec cette petite cet étui à
cigarettes c'est la taille d'un étui à
cigarettes
ouais c'est ça c'est vrai que ce
dispositif de miniatures et de bois de
fermer c'était peut-être une manière de
les rendre plus acceptable mais je pense
pas que ce soit de la censure de
l'autocensure de ma part c'était aussi
une manière de recréer une sorte de
peepshow comme ça parce qu'on est obligé
de de s'approcher d'ouvrir la boîte ya
un petit peu il ya une surprise un jeu
avec le regardeur qui s'établit et puis
c'est aussi une manière pour pour les
collectionneurs d'offrir d'offrir ce cet
objet sans choquer le destinateur le
dessinateur à un premier coup quelle est
la clé pour vous l'avantagent de la
peinture sur la photo et la vidéo
justement alors je dirais que quand on
quand on parle de porno on convoque la
vidéo ou la photo mais la pornographie
elle est encore le lieu de la peinture
ou de la littérature
j'ai l'impression qu'on n'utilise pas le
même mot pour pour ce pour cesser ces
pratiques artistiques et est justement
la vidéo ou la photo font appel à des
vrais gens donc il ya une une empathie
voir une répulsion qui peut s'opérer
alors que la littérature ou la peinture
ce qui nous occupe dans ce projet c'est
une création
moi je suis pas photographe je suis
peintre justement parce que
je transforme de la matière je manipule
des pigments de la feuille d'or il ya
une sensualité évidente dans la peinture
que je ne retrouverais c'est peut-être
pas dans la photo il ya un côté hors du
temps dans vos peintures elle aurait pu
tout à peu près être réalisée il ya 100
ou 150 ans est-ce que c'est fait exprès
oui parce que et dans le choix même des
images dans les cadrages j'avais envie
de sortir justement du temps et de
l'espace
d'une certaine manière pour pour accéder
à une sorte oui d'intemporel parce que
la pornographie justement elle peut
s'inscrire dans un débat assez houleux
dans des polémiques elle et elle a un
parfum de scandale elle est un potentiel
polémique très fort mais à grâce à la
peinture et à cette technique de
peinture à l'huile
j'avais envie justement de déplacer ce
de déplacer ce sujet et d'en faire à en
faire de la peinture tout simplement
est-ce que ça n'est pas pour ça aussi
que vous les avaient enfermés dans des
petites boîtes à bijoux serre pour au
fond pour leur redonner quelque chose de
d'un peu au fond d'un peu interdit à une
époque où ça l'est de moins en moins un
complètement
oui oui le fait de les dissimuler ça les
rend encore plus obscène d'une certaine
manière puisque l'obsède c'est
finalement tout montrer mais ce tout
c'est ce qu'il ne faut pas montrer donc
en les cachant on multiplie encore cet
interdit tout h f l'exposition il y
avait une exposition prévue qui
malheureusement a été annulé du fait du
coc bide en tout cas reportés c'était
ton regard moderne je crois à la libye
pourtant il ya eu déjà une exposition
qui a été fait je crois boston alors
qu'elle a été là
réaction des gens qui sont venus la voir
en plus alors à boston c'est vraiment
c'est quasiment la capitale du plus haut
terril à nice mammeri qu on peut pas
faire du tout à fait là vraiment dans le
fief ouest de la côte est
eh bien écoutez j'ai été très surprise
de la réception de cette exposition
alors peut-être parce qu'il ya pas
beaucoup il ya très peu d'offres
il ya très peu d'art érotique d'ailleurs
je me demande si c'est pas un peu pour
ça que j'avais commencé ces miniatures
quand je vivais là bas parce que j'étais
un petit peu en manque de 7 de ceux de
cet aspect charnelle des choses mais en
fait la plupart des deux mais
collectionneurs pour 7 pour cette
exposition était des femmes qui étaient
absolument ravis de se les faire offrir
ou de les offrir elle même à leur
compagnon et elle était elle était
vraiment très assez émoustillé et très y
avait un petit parfum de rébellion et
[Musique]
beaucoup aimé à jeudi elle parce que
c'était vraiment la majorité des des
acheteurs s était très contente de
s'offrir ce petit oui c'est cette
obscénité comme ça en boîte mais en les
enfermant dans des boîtes à bijoux est
ce que vous vous condamnez pas justement
à à ce que vos acheteuse vos
collectionneuse soient des femmes
au fond un homme qui aurait envie de
collectionner vos peintures peut-être il
voudrait les avoir comme ça et pas
forcément dans une boîte à bijoux
alors ça m'est arrivé de retirer la
peinture de sa boîte et de la l'exposé
pas de la mettre dans un cadre haut sur
toile non il ya aussi des hommes qui
m'ont qui vont acheter des boîtes pour
les offrir ou à s'offrir des femmes
oui la question que je me pose toujours
j'imagine que si vous étiez un homme
vous auriez pain de la même manière
comme l'ont fait tous les peintres
depuis la nuit des temps vous auriez pas
des femmes nues mais étant une femme
pourrait s'attendre ce que vous payez
des hommes nus
il y en a quelques uns mais il y en a
quand même - vous êtes quand même vous
êtes vraiment vous les femmes le sexe
qui se préfère au fond
alors je me suis beaucoup posé la
question et je pense que j'ai entamé ce
projet aussi pour répondre à cette
question puisque au début je faisais pas
du tout deux corps masculins je n'y
arrivais pas non pas que je n'arrivais
pas à dessiner le corps de l'homme mais
je n'arrivais pas à le rendre érogènes
j'arrivais à le composer dans mes
petites s'est petit à petit je suis
arrivé il faut dire alors il faut dire
deux choses soit j'ai un modèle soit
j'ai un modèle qui est assez rare soit
je n'en ai pas dans ce cas là je vais
faire des recherches sur internet et
bien pour trouver des belles images
d'hommes nus c'est très très compliqué
il faut il faut aller sur des sites gays
tout simplement
donc c'est vrai que la production de
d'imagés érotiques masculine est assez
rare en tout cas moi une celle qui me
plaisait et ai été assez rare et d'autre
part je pense après y avoir pas mal
réfléchi
les femmes qui ont choisi de faire des
des représentations érotique ou
pornographique sont assez rares elles
ont commencé toute assez récemment
l'émancipation de la femme et on va dire
battre d'un demi siècle
donc je pense que on est encore en tout
cas pour ma génération dans la
réappropriation de nos corps de pouvoir
mettre dans un auto érotisme
puisqu'avant notre corps ils étaient
mobilisés est représentée par des hommes
maintenant à nous de le faire à nous de
leur présenter tel qui peut nous nous
exciter ou tel qu'on a envie de le voir
reproduit mais je vois quand même la
toute jeune génération qui
qui a plus de liberté par rapport au
corps de l'homme eh bien en attendant
l'exposition après le confinement il y a
donc le livre d'aurélie gallois bijoux
indiscrets ses sorties dans les
collections érotique
[Musique]
si la sba ça vous vous êtes pianiste
vous êtes compositeur vous êtes argentin
votre vous sortez votre troisième album
vous l'avais appelé silas pourquoi silas
d'ailleurs les deux précédents
s'appelait oscillations et et du ahly tu
as pourquoi donner à celui-ci votre
prénom qui est aussi d'ailleurs celui
d'un compagnon de 2,2 de saint paul de
port louis
je connais bien l'histoire en fait là
l'histoire on a appris ça près parce que
comme ma mère mamie sylla c'est le
connaissais pas cette histoire
elle avait juste entendu ce prénom
dans sa ville d'origine à lapins pas en
argentine et à un vieux monsieur qui
s'appelait silas est soit y avait
tellement plus qu'elle a gardé en tête
après la rencontre et mon père et elle
m'a eue si elle m'a mise si lasse donc
en fait je les remercie beaucoup parce
que c'est un prénom presque prédestiné
parce que il ya deux notes de musique
presque 3 6 la seule aussi là si on peut
les entendre comme on veut donc c'est
oui c'est un prénom musicale c'est un
prénom effectivement biblique
jallet a pris après et ben c'est simple
pourquoi si là c'est parce que c'est le
premier album ou jeu de voiles dix
compositions à moi c'est à dire qu'avant
dans les autres deux albums précédents
il ya quelques compositions à moi mais
mélangé à d'autres compositeurs qui
manquent mais on sait qu'ils m'ont
inspiré comme phil glass ouganda goff
ravel debussy donc et donc je traduisais
mes compositions à l'intérieur deux de
ses autres compositeurs donc je me
mélange est avec eux et chose qui me
plaisait beaucoup à faire et j'étais
très content mais j'ai compris
très vite en fait quand j'ai fini mon
deuxième album doit l'état et qu'on
était en mixage en fait aux studios en
réécoutant l'enregistrement j'ai compris
à ce moment là j'étais très content de
l'enregistrement mais je compris à ce
moment là que cette étape de construire
de programmes des albums où je mélange
de compositions à d'autres compositeurs
était finie et que même si l'album donc
été même pas sorti dans l'it à ce moment
là il fallait attendre six mois sept
mois presque pour glisseurs pour moi
c'était déjà une étape fini et je
commençais déjà à imaginer un troisième
album que des compositions
donc c'est pour moi un défi
effectivement c'est une évolution au
fait que qui s'est fait d'album en album
et donc quand j'ai cherché un titre je
n'arrivais pas à trouver un nom de
quelque chose comme je sais pas
répression comme on fait souvent des
titres qui peut se juger suggérer
quelque chose et je trouvais que
finalement pourquoi pas la blesse silas
puisque c'est mon premier album on va
dire c'est le 3e c'est le premier
autoréférentielle et c'est un
autoportrait en fait donc voilà si la ce
on regarde tout de suite mais il ya un
clip qui est sortie pour cet album on
regarde tout de suite un extrait de
katia the runaway un des morceaux de ce
disque
[Musique]
moi
silas vous avez vous n'êtes pas
commencer vous avez une formation
classique vous n'avez pas commencé le
piano à l'âge de 16 ans comme yaron
herman vous l'avait commencée à quoi
trois ans quatre ans oui moi c'est le
parcours le celui qu'on connaît plus
peut-être c'est celui de wii tout petit
cinq ans oui en fait c'est grâce aussi à
ma mère parce que ma mère de jouer un
peu de piano
ben il avait l'avait fait aussi piano en
compte elle était jeune et donc ce piano
partenaires à elle et j'avais la chance
d'avoir ce piano à la maison ce qui m'a
permis de le découvrir d'une façon très
spontanée et très naturelle et très
naturellement donc je me suis mis devant
je commençais à jouer tout seul
en fait pendant que ma mère travaillait
à côté dans son cabinet d'avocats
j'étais dans le salon de piano et à
l'écouté l'entendait que justement j'ai
essayé de jouer des choses et pas
seulement m'amuser en fait comme un
petit enfant qui va peut-être même vous
l'a peut-être cassé piano mais bon soit
disant qu'elle pensait qu'ils aient déjà
il y avait quelque chose de particulier
donc c'est là j'ai la chance d'avoir une
mère en fait qui a compris ça très très
vite et qui m'a encouragée dès le départ
à apprendre de cours et piano donc de
tout petits vous êtes arrivé à paris en
2000 vous nous le raconte y est tout à
l'heure depuis vous êtes resté alors il
ya un autre morceau de vous tous
j'aimerais qu'on entende un extrait lui
aussi est en vidéo même s'il n'est pas
dans le dernier album mais c'est un
morceau précédent
c'est paris villepinte on va regarder un
extrait
[Musique]
à
silas base ça vous l'avez dit votre
parcours et est classique on commence le
piano très jeune on est doué on va faire
le conservatoire
ensuite on va faire des concours vous
avez gagné une bourse vous êtes arrivé à
paris on fait des concerts
il ya un moment il ya le déclic créatif
dont parlait yaron herman tout à l'heure
qui fait qu'on va devenir compositeur
s'est pas à mon avis tout le monde à la
tentation on peut imaginer que des très
grands pianistes comme arthur rubinstein
samson françois avait peut-être aussi
envie de composer quelque chose ils ne
l'ont pas fait en train de nous l'ont
jamais fait entendre un moment on
bascule quand on devient compositeur et
on va être jugés non plus comme un
interprète mais comme quelqu'un qui veut
se mettre sur le même plan que beethoven
chopin ou ou ou ou duke ellington
comment ça se passe pourquoi un moment
on s'aide ah ça oui c'est intéressant de
passer justement il ya eu un déclic
comme vous dites ce déclic s'est passé
en 2007 2008
donc je suis arrivé à un stade où
j'étais en train encore de prendre des
cours de piano avec
un grand maître ici à paris monique des
chaussées est en fête
je me rappelle quand elle me dit alors
l'année prochaine qu'est ce qu'on va
faire on va faire un une sonate de
chemins où il nous faudra faire un
brahms ou une et là j'ai compris qu'en
fait est ce que j'ai vraiment besoin en
vie en fait plutôt envie de
de jouer encore une sonate de quiconque
et comment continuer à cette idée qu'il
faut faire du répertoire qu'il faut
s'enrichir de tout ça et en fait j'ai
compris que mes envies n'était plus là
les attentes des autres n'étaient plus
les miennes parce qu'en fait il faut
savoir que quand on vit tout près ce que
j'ai pas 30 ans dans ce milieu forcément
les gens attendent de nous attendre de
moi attendaient des mois ça attendez moi
le pianiste classique et donc en fait ça
a été plutôt un travail que j'ai dû
faire très intérieur avec moi-même en
fait
très difficile très il fallait beaucoup
de courage donc j'ai décidé de couper
les cours déjà donc deux pas des pas
avoir aucune influence de ce milieu en
tout cas classique et de d'essayer de me
retrouver moi même et ça c'est à ce
moment là que j'ai commencé à faire la
danse je prenais des cours de danse
contemporaine martha graham et j'ai
commencé à avoir beaucoup de spectacles
au théâtre de la ville notamment de
danse et donc des spectacles comme
intéresser les quinze mecs qui m'ont
beaucoup marqué et c'est à travers ses
spectacles où je découvre aussi des
musiques qui accompagnent ce spectacle
de danse et de théâtre contemporain et
cd musique justement comme vous dites
qu'ils veulent pas se placer dans une
lignée quelconque que c'est pas c'est
par on dit pas bon c'est là c'est la
continuité de beethoven 2 de brahms ou
de rosé stravinsky et j'ai trouvé qu'il
y avait une certaine liberté dont le nom
de ce milieu dans tout cas de musique
qui accompagnait la danse ou le théâtre
et que ça m'amusait en fait justement
d'explorer à travers à travers ça il ya
travers aussi les musiques de films
parce que j'ai aussi une culture
cinéphile très très grande
donc en fait je pense que je ne suis pas
fait que de culture classique c'est ça
qu'il faut comprendre c'est que dès tout
petit j'ai joué aussi beaucoup de
musique folklore de mon pays j'ai joué
du tango j'étais toujours attiré par des
influences multiples en fait donc en
fait il fallait juste que je dise mans
le classique
ça m'a apporté énormément parce que
effectivement ce que ce que là où je
suis fier c'est que quand je compose
pour moi parce que pour l'instant aussi
je ne compose que pour moi même donc
c'est des pièces au piano que je joue je
suis donc compositeur interprète mais je
me rends compte que cette technique et
tous ces années de piano de travail très
difficiles parfois bien sûr j'ai passé
des moments très angoissant de trêve à
je pleurais aussi petit avec des maîtres
vraiment à l'ancienne mais tous à tous
et rigueur en fait tu m'as donné
aujourd'hui une liberté que comme je
suis au piano en fait c c'est vraiment
un pur plaisir parce que en jouant de ma
musique je retrouve aussi ce double
plaisir qui est la liberté ii
pianistique physique que j'ai pour pour
jouer autant que je veux et comme je
veux et aussi je voulais dire que dans
mon entraînement quotidien
comment parler comme il parlait yaron en
plus de la créativité
je continue à travailler aussi des
pièces pour moi de répertoire classique
donc j'aime beaucoup
j'ai pas un jour me faire quelques
prélude de bach quinze jours je me fais
quelques ballades de chopin quelques
sonates de beethoven des scarlatti donc
ça m'accompagne toujours c'est à dire
que j'ai pas éliminé quoi que ce soit
c'est un tout c'est vraiment ses
multiples choses qui m'ont influencé qui
que je continue à développer maintenant
à travers la musique
merci silas basse à votre troisième
album donc avec uniquement des
compositions personnelles s'intitule
silas il est dans tous les bacs
les concerts en revanche mais il faudra
attendre la fin du confinement pour vous
voir de nouveau sur scène merci de nous
avoir suivis et rendez vous au prochain
numéro
[Musique]